2009 10 wird zum ersten mal in
deutschland cannabis legal geerntet
allerdings damit zu medizinischen
zwecken eingesetzt werden warum kann
aber es jetzt zur kassenleistung
geworden ist das jetzt weiß ich zum
science fiction montur fahrzeug auf
[Musik]
cannabis ist ja eine droge die relativ
ungefährlich ist im gegensatz zu alkohol
macht sie zum beispiel deutlich weniger
abhängig und es gibt nahezu keine toten
durch kamen allerdings schränkt das
enthaltene thc die hirnfunktion stark
ein aber es hat eben auch medizinische
wochen bereits vor 4754 jahren im fall
der chinesische kaiser sendung darf von
cannabis bei diversen beschwert
überliefert wird das durch die pflanzen
kompendium shadow banking so um wer
heute ist klar kann aviv bei übelkeit
erbrechen starken schmerzen oder auch
multipler sklerose
jetzt wird der anbau für cannabis in
deutschland für medizinische zwecke
legalisiert dafür wird beim
bundesinstitut für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte eigens eine cannabis
agentur begründet sie soll den
cannabisanbau in deutschland überwachen
und sie wird die legalisierung mit einer
wissenschaftlichen studie begleiten noch
dieses jahr wird sie in den anbau von
cannabis in deutschland ausschreiben und
den anschluss aufträge vergeben ich bin
ja mal sehr gespannt wer sich dadurch
wird für erste ernsten werden für 2009
10 erwartet die ernte wird dann immer
von der cannabis agentur in ihrem besitz
genommen und dann über apotheken
abgegeben das beste die krankenkassen
zahlen so dass cannabis bisher mussten
dass nämlich die meisten patienten mit
einer ausnahmegenehmigung selbst machen
da konnten dann schon mal monatlich bis
zu 800 euro fällig wäre dieser schritt
wird vor allem schwerkranken helfen die
ansonsten keine möglichkeit haben ihr
leiden zu lindern
so wird cannabis dann zum beispiel im
rahmen einer chemotherapie verschrieben
bei krebskranken oder bei aids-patienten
gegen übelkeit und appetitlosigkeit
zudem hilft es diesen patienten damit
gegen die schwächung und hält die
stimmung auf was für diese patienten
einen nicht zu unterschätzenden
therapeutischen wert hat mehr über
cannabis gibt es übrigens in unserem
großen special zum thema dafür hier
draufklicken und zurück mehr unbedingt
ein abo auf auge da ihr dafür hier
klicken
warten auf die glocke da verpasst ihr
nämlich nicht mehr wie findet ihr die
legalisierung diskutiertes mit mir in
den kommentaren und ansonsten bislang
bleibt kann